[Music]
in 20 seconds we gotta go little rascal
do you think the princess should have a
red dress like mine ready
where's this e they say miss missing
sorry Mac they haven't seen her miss a
moose kid I didn't know what to do I
like fighting ground teams found the
truck in the mountains I'm really sorry
mr. Phillips
Oh some help over there I'm okay well
it's better than I maybe next time I'm
super sorry so much already I don't want
to lose the letter showed up in my
mailbox the no tracks in the snow
you're not thinking about going back
Rory I got to do something you know this
isn't a good idea
it's crazy that's all I got
got a fire going inside if you want to
warm up
their kids ain't Allen Philips in
looking forward to this I know you very
well that we go work on that he's still
having a hard time believing this is
real why did you bring me there's no
easy answer they'll take your pain away
where were you when I needed you never
left
ain't it just like a team to go and blue
or might I forgive him own in the hurt I
can you hurt me you're the promise of a
pain for your life yeah there isn't yeah
when the pain you can do this on your
own can see this dish is lying lesson
[Music]
working for Howard Hughes no harm having
high hopes ma'am and what church to go
to frame First Methodist and Fresno I
forgive you she's giving we're back